[Music]
stand up
the spider before
[Music]
[Applause]
go giant truck
being around 222 forage of all they
don't even uh Mike field I believe of a
peddlers for Richard and what a great
job is they I've been out there for two
males in 21 minutes plus at this time is
Richard coming onto the Arts for the
time proxies hyperbolas ways on
congratulations region
[Applause]
looking good rich how you feeling
looking good keep it up brother
[Applause]
spotlight
[Music]
around 70 59 pointy likes to go as a
yoga this time there as we said no s 715
for yet you had that to his time of 1638
32 that puts believe Jochen there with a
time of 24 25 31
and look how close it was Richard 20
point 30 31 so look how close that was
because as we said to you earlier we
have seen some amazing times we had rip
finishing in 24 1750 and there's two
guys within 13 minutes of that position
six and seven overall so sixth place
overall in the ultraman World
Championships goes to your condemned
bank of Germany seventh place overall
goes to Richard roll from the US at 24
30 31 just 5 minutes exactly separating
these two guys and our congrats and
thanks to their crews as well what a
wonderful job they did and thanks to
Judy thoughtless wife dick feller
Angelique Stevens and Laurie Montgomery
the paddler that's for the man from
Cologne Germany and for Richard roll his
pair that was Mike fuel his wife Julie
is here and his sons Tyler and trapper
finish line there thanks also to Alan
Blackburn
[Music]
[Applause]
in the cycling as well
[Music]
through this best in this race 3201
it is the place to be let it happen you
feel the cool breeze
kiss the son
[Music]
tree
everyone
every laugh every scream every cry every
joy
Oh
[Music]
you
come on people